how you guys doing today
welcome to the quiet of studio with your
faces surrounding you as you speak yes
thank you so much for coming today it's
always nice to talk to a to a fellow
Vincent I am Vincent Mancuso with
collider.com
and this is Vincent D'Onofrio director
of the kid and with him is his amazing
cast
Jake sure and Laila George I just want a
such fun jump right in because it's very
interesting to me when when we get a
Western in these days cuz the westerns
have been around since since movies have
been around and I'm wondering but what
drew you to the genre and and how you
found this story because it's kind of
historical it's also a coming-of-age
tale I'm wondering how you found the way
into this story well I always wanted to
make a Western and I wrote one a long
time ago and then it just got caught up
in all this kind of lawyer stuff and
wasn't able to be made and so I I wanted
to make one for a long time I mean it's
just to think of an original story in an
original way to approach us and it's
difficult because the genre has been
around for so long and basically it's
usually about the same sort of stuff you
know unless you're unless like The
Searchers or something which isn't
amazing no living but um and but then
you know years passed and I started
getting into watching these
coming-of-age type stories of young men
that started to interest me and and then
one night I just thought of that
I could add a what would be like if I
added a kid to an actual factual outlaw
story like to stick with the facts about
these kind of outlaws from the West but
add a fictional character into it and I
thought it would be perfect for Pat
Garrett and Billy the Kid because
Garrett is one type of man and Billy's
another to have a boy to have his
journey be influenced by those two types
of men and become a man by the end of
the movie would be an interesting way to
make a Western and Jake as the kid this
is your first your first role your first
screen role and I think I read that you
you first met on the pawn shop
chronicles the set of the pawn shop
chronicles that I'm wondering what the
what the journey has been like from from
that meeting to starring in the kid what
we meant I can't remember the first time
we met would I remember it was brief
like can you yeah and then we met and
then Sam majors office yes and that's
when I decided that I took him we went
into another room in the other office do
you remember that yes you gave me some
sort of test I gave you a little
exercise will after exercise yeah what
was the test it was it was basically to
get to see if he could use two parts of
his brain at the same time to see if he
can see the part mentalizing emotion and
speak the author's words to do them
simultaneously and to you know to be
able to because that's what acting is
and you know and I never forgot it and
so when would they kept on saying when
are you going to start looking for an
actor when you're gonna start looking
for an active eclis the kid in the cast
we finally got a casting agent and then
the first conversation that I had with
her about casting was we were looking
for Billy the Kid and then we were
supposed to go on to looking for Rio and
it was the first time I'd been put in
that position to talk about the actors
that I wanted to play Rio and I said you
know can we just not talk about it can
we just not talk about Rio I think I
have Rio
but then I hadn't spoken to his father
yet so you know that was so out of that
house to tell that conversation go it
went really well I mean he wanted that
for him you know so it wasn't hard to
convince him it was just that you know
you're asking for you come in I didn't
know Jordan very well I just knew him a
little bit he produced another movie
that I was in but you're asking for all
this money for him to raise all this
money for you to make this Western about
Billy the Kid and Pat Garrett and you
suddenly say you know I want to use a
young boy that's never done anything and
so that's a little the hard sell yeah
but I couldn't I couldn't think of
anybody else I couldn't there's so much
acting from young people go on going on
these days but not the kind of acting I
think I thought that would fit into our
movie with with experienced actors like
my daughter and like in like Ethan Hawke
and Dane DeHaan and Chris Pratt you know
I wanted a certain you know I didn't
want a young actor II kid I wanted to
have a real human being in the part and
so Jake has this ability to show his
human side and act at the same time and
I thought that's what was needed for the
movie and then you brought your daughter
along for the ride as well and I'm
wondering what that on the day on set
what what that's like for both of you
having to having to you know place your
daughter where she needs to go how to
tell her back and then having your
father basically telling you what to do
in that scene I'm just wondering what
that what that relationship is like I
said do you put aside the the family
stuff or is it or is it more of a
familiar situation oh it was put aside
every it was like on set director
actress relationship and at the same
time it's awesome like we're making
jokes every now and then when it's
appropriate and you know he's my dad so
I'm sidled up to him a lot and on his
shoulder and you know but then then
we're doing these crazy intense scenes
you know stuff gets pretty rough for the
two of us
and and my dad's in the corner of the
room with a monitor and it's it's it's
incredibly surreal to be in that place
with all of these thoughts and memories
going on and and there he is and it's
useful as well
it's all awesome there's nothing bad
about it there's known there was no
negative for me everything was really
cool and just and just the fact that
he's my dad just also helps that she's a
good actress
yeah because otherwise it would be
really difficult and I'm curious because
you're coming off of immortal engines
which is this massive thing it's his
massive green scene thing and I'm
wondering what the comparison was like
for you to come into this which correct
me if I'm wrong everything looked very
practical look like you had build set so
yeah we shot it in 28 days 28 20 days
Jesus it was craves a complete was
awesome because it was a completely
opposite experience I just done this
gigantic thing with where everything is
just huge and and then to do this where
we're moving really fast and trying to
get the day done and I really liked it
you know the I loved I'm you know he's
being very nice and saying that I'm very
good and very experienced but I'm really
a baby in this I started acting late and
these are still my first jobs and so
this was a new experience for me
doing something where we got one or two
takes and when he was happy we were we
were on to the next thing there's no
opportunity to second-guess or throw up
but I see I don't know what I just I
mean really and I trusted him so that
was okay but it was it was actually nice
to go from one to the other and to you
know where everyone's tied or Ned in a
real
and I was really cool to do those two
completely opposite things in the same
year I'm curious about that because you
mentioned this is these are very early
days for you as an actress and this is
your first movie and I wonder if that's
something you guys sort of need a
bonding over or helped you find a
connection as playing siblings but the
fact that you're both you know not
newcomers but you're very yeah yeah
there was that look there was an element
of that there's also an element of the
fact that I have three younger brothers
and he kind of just slotted himself in
and it was great you know I haven't seen
him for a year he's now taller than me
and it's prepared and but it's awesome
to see him you know I think about I
think about him a lot I'm always
wondering what he's do we got really
close I thought we did different but I
thought we got right he was like you
know to the point where he would get on
my nerves so much that I would go to my
dad like Jake's being mean time anyway
you know but we got really close but I
was very very happy to be able to work
with such an incredible actress before I
should really know whatever amazing it's
out it just sounds like this was a very
not small operation but it's very
tight-knit operation you guys were sort
of out there in New Mexico you it was
I'm curious about the production itself
did you tell me what was it was it local
local workers did you did you bring in
the local craftsman stuff like that to
build the sets was it was it a very you
know non la experience a non studio
experience for you very non studio
experience and a lot of the workers a
lot of the crew was we're local a lot of
the camera crew but have worked together
before but were for everybody was from
close by and and the set decorators and
the and the set builders and
all of the the jobs the collaborative
jobs that happen around a movie were
very local and some some key people were
brought in from New York and the the our
costume designer rubric at Elias and our
DP matthew lloyd they were brought in
from new york and Sarah Kay white our
production designer she was brought in
from New York but these are people that
I picked because of their work you know
and I knew that they were they could
make small films look really good and
that's why they were all there but but
it was very very small anything and and
in addition to directing you play a very
small role you play very small share for
all you have and I tried to weasel out
of that part but interesting wise they
wouldn't let me I just didn't want to
you know ice kept on saying yeah I do
what you know cuz the producers put
together the whole package with my main
part of the package as an actor too so
so I always kind of had in the back of
my mind to just kind of cast somebody
else and during the casting period with
the locals in in in New Mexico I kept on
saying well he would also make a good
chair for Romero
much better than me but then when it
came down to it Jordans shirt producer
said no you have to play the sheriff so
I'm like okay I'm please chef well it's
interesting to me because I'm wondering
what it's what that's like on the day
when you're when you're directing and
acting on the same is it sort of do you
have to shut off part of your brain for
for a hot second to do the role and then
turn it back on and yeah and when you
are directing you're sort of you know in
full cowboy regalia I'm wondering what
that's like what's it like in the moment
when you are both acting and directing
at the same time it's not that it's not
as difficult as you would think your
you know you trust the actors that are
around you trust your cameraman you
trust the the everybody watching it be
shot all your artists that are
collaborative you know collaborative in
the movie and and so you have a lot of
good people to depend on that or not
when you're not behind the camera at the
time so there was never this feeling of
you know this this is kind of different
or this may not work or no it's kind of
I I know how to act so it that's the
easy part
it was nice that the part was so small
and in a way it's a little bit
significant but not much so I just had
to kind of add my little color to the
film as an actors and it wasn't hard to
jump back and forth and I also had my
buddy Ethan there Ethan Hawke and I are
very good friends and I had most of my
dial all my dialogue with him so you
know he would tell me we constantly feel
open enough with each other to to give
each other notes on our acting all the
time when we're together or even when
we're not together so that was all very
free it wasn't a problem at all actually
I mean I I would prefer to do the next
one that I'm gonna do
I would forgot to be in it at all though
mmm you'd want to be like the Hitchcock
who just pops up and in all the movies
no no but but I would like to direct a
movie where I was had a big part in it
but but I don't like I'd like to figure
out this whole directing thing first and
then maybe do that this movie also
features Chris Pratt in by far probably
the biggest dirtbag role he's ever had
easy
I don't sure wait a Velen before and he
plays a pretty despicable person in this
movie I'm wondering for everyone that's
just not the Chris Pratt that that that
you know the audience knows I'm
wondering what it was like to coax that
performance out of him and I'm wondering
what it was like to play across from him
in that role
um well I mean he'd go back and forth
between choking me out and screaming and
then you know Vincent would yell cut me
out you all right you all right a very
nice guy and I don't know how he
switched that on and off went back and
forth between the nice guy that he is in
playing this so believably such a
horrible such a horrendous person you
know doing these horrible things and
yeah he did a great job at it and it was
wonderful work yeah I mean like he said
Chris is such a lovely human being that
he's saying these terrible things to you
screaming right here in your face and
then it's cut and he's like oh my gosh I
have to hug you like I you know and then
you do and it's and it's it's super
impressive watching him watching Jake
around that too you know if I I was his
age and there's this you know prominent
figure in the room doing all of this
kind of stuff you know he held his own
so much around you know he was you
forget you forget that this is his first
thing you forget you know because it it
was really impressive and especially
just to be around those high players
you forget that he's new you know it's
it was really cool you know what Chris
when it's interesting to get to meet
actors and to see who they are when
they're not on screen to see what kind
of human being they are you know and
like Chris like all of us have as many
different sides and so you know I knew
that my feeling was is that it was a
really good idea for him to play this
this bad guy and I had a feeling that he
was going to do it because of that and
it just seemed to work out that way he
was interested in the part because of
what a disgusting character the guy was
and so you know he came in to play and
to do things I have a particular way of
directing that that people understand
when they when they're coming in Dane
was the only one that I didn't really
know and didn't he didn't know about me
very much
so I had to make sure that Dane
understood that you know it's all a
collaborative effort and
[Music]
I like to put my hands in everybody's
business you know like when they're
acting and I involve myself in their
performances and and they have to be
strong enough to maintain their
character and come up with the goods at
the same time listening and to me and
taking direction and in a very very
particular way and so you know Chris was
so is was like that he was so open and
and ready to go and he knew what he had
to accomplish he came in from another
project coming came in for five days
shot all of his stuff in five days and
then and then left but brought in this
amazing performance and he did he got
into a space in the scenes in the bar he
got into a really different space for
him he he locked into this other side of
himself and then you know what for it
that interesting stuff ya know for sure
and that collaboration that you again
you're mentioning the very close process
that you're describing is very
interesting to me because I feel like
over the years as an actor you become
known for for making very interesting
choices in the moment they're playing
with roles in ways that aren't expected
and I'm wondering as a director if you
ever find it hard to take a step back
and and trust the decisions or that just
the choices in the moment that another
performer is making that that new maybe
would not have made in that same
situation yeah I mean it's inspiring it
but it inspires me to go further you
know to watch them do their thing if
they're doing stuff that I've never seen
before
then I'm happy if they're doing stuff
that I've seen a million times I'm I'm
not happy
that there you have to get actor to
expose themselves while in character
while walking and talking like this
character but they need to expose
themselves to the to us and as if
they're turning their selves inside-out
and when you get an actor to do that
you're seeing something brand new
because it's that individual person
doing it you've never seen it before and
so if that's happening I stay out of it
if that's not I help them get to that
point because I know how to do it mmm
and they know I know how to do it you
know so it's there's a trust and a
collaboration with it it's not just them
and it's not just me it's it's us making
this story and it's all about servicing
the story and that's that's the key and
I think that's comes by I think by his
nature is to do that he's a reader he
reads a lot for a young man which is
awesome his taste in films is really
good he's innate ly now since he's done
it he's innately made as an actor to
service a story rather than to be in it
for the for the papas of it and Leila
grew up like that she grew up with
actors that have been struggling to
service stories her whole life and so
she naturally falls into that and then
you meet guys like Dane DeHaan who
that's that's what he does for a living
he services stories every part that he
plays is it's definitely not about him
it's about story and and then Chris and
and Ethan too so it's you know that's
the main thing that's the that's
that's the thing I think that if I when
I when I when I do this next film that
I'm gonna do I think that it will be
it'll be cast because of that element I
think that's the best way for me
personally to go amazing and before we
wrap up this is this sounds like a very
intense very close-knit very small very
you know just involve production and I'm
wondering for each of you what what
specific moment out there you know in
the New Mexico desert really will will
stick with you long after this long
after this movie comes out what moment
really just springs to mind about the
production that that will never you'll
never forget my first day was maybe a
week into them shooting already and I
was so nervous and we were all sitting
in a everyone was in there it was like
this big dinner table scene and they
Ethan's to my left and Jake's in front
of me Danes there my dad's in another
room and just like you know when you can
feel it beating out of your chest and we
do the scene mmm and we cut and my dad
comes out and makes this little speech
that I can't talk about because it'll
just make me cry but it was just you
know the first time that we'd worked
together and it was really it was really
beautiful and I just will remember that
forever ever it was was so awesome to
work with you
it was really cool I'm really I feel
really lucky that we were able to do
this that got your beard you have to
follow I'll try my best
um I would say was towards the end of
the shoot
it was around 4:30 or 5:00 in the
morning we're shooting the scene when
we're fleeing the cabin where our pants
were just murdered and Chris Pratt is we
know he's gonna follow us our uncle and
it's freezing freezing out this is a New
Mexico morning I had all these people
out there and this field and you know
the wilderness and I just remember just
thinking this was something special as
you know all these people out here you
know together to create something I just
remember them it was very memorable
memorable to me amazing and as the
director of the project what is what is
something that that's just gonna just
gonna stick with you long after this
this movie comes out
I you know just the the there's the
other there are key moments to every
couple of days when you're shooting
there are key things that happen that
you know are going to help the movie you
know storytelling moments and things and
so each of these people even Dame Chris
Jake Leila each of them had a couple of
those moments in the movie and so those
like I could talk to in detail mm-hmm
about each of those moments and how they
happened and how I saw it happen and
those are the moments that I'm always
going to remember because I watched the
story unfold from their from their
humility like as the characters you know
they're and and so that's a very unique
thing to see if you've written the story
and and you're directing it to watch
each key character service the story in
such a very specific way through this
kind of
private humility of their own fantastic
stuff that just it's in my mind like it
happened yesterday each and every one of
them and even the most skilled actors
like Ethan you know he's this amazingly
skilled actor there are moments where I
would go up and say things to him and he
would say things to me while the camera
was still rolling we would have a very
brief little conversation and then
suddenly the next take would be so full
of humility that it was like wow you
know it's like [ __ ] that guy's good now
that that's like we're doing the right
thing right now what's gonna happen an
hour from now I have no idea but right
now we're doing really good it was
generally such a beautiful set to be on
but it really felt like a family you
know dad and Ethan and Chris are like
brothers and and I've known Ethan for a
while and and Jake came in and
immediately just felt like family and my
cousin walked and off riyo dad's nephew
was was on set for sidekick and Dane had
just had a baby beautiful like literally
the most beautiful blue-eyed thing
you'll ever see she is gorgeous and so
he it was really nice because he would
say that it was nice very it was his
first job that he'd done since his wife
had given birth he'd spent time at home
and he liked that this was the job he
was on because it felt like a family and
seeing father/daughter working together
and he's just become a father to a
daughter and so it had a lot of nice
symbolism the whole thing it really was
just beautiful right I just felt like
that was you know just a big but it was
you asked about the best moments and it
was a lot of great moments
amazing I think that's a gorgeous note
to go on go out on thank you guys so
much for being here again and we'll kid
in theaters go see it